♪ ♪ ♪
- Voir la planète
s'effondrer en direct à la télé,
ce sont des images qui laissent
sans mot et qui peuvent
de colère et d'impuissance.
De quoi, même, rendre Simon
Goulet-Tinaoui écoanxieux.
SIMON GOULET-TINAOUI
un emploi, d'avoir une maison.
C'est ça, un peu, le récit
du progrès, mais d'un autre
est voué, d'une certaine façon,
qu'on n'aura pas les conditions
de base.n n n n n n n n n n n ne
l'nxnxnxiété pendant des mois.
Un sentiment d'anxiété profondts
causés par les chaenenents
climatiques et l'appréhensionen.
Il s'est senerererdu.
- Entre qui je suis,quququququq,
c'est quoi mes buts, puis
la situation anticipée...
Ça va être quoi, le futur,
- L'écoanxiété est
de plus en ppapapapandue.
Noémie Larouche, une journaliste
scientifique, a écrit
NOÉMIE LAROUCHE, autrice,
"Éétététété, l'envers du déni"
- C'est un trouble réel, reconnu
comme tel par l'Association
trouble qui est défini
e e e e une peur chronique
du désastre environnemental.
- Certains spécialistes
de stress prétraumatique. Isabei
vécu de l'écoanxiété.
Elle a décidé de fonder-m-m-m-m,
un collectif de professionnels
qui donnent des ateliers dans
les cégeps et universités
pour aider les gen l l l l l l .
ISABELLE BÉLIVEAU, cofondatrice
et coordonatrice, Éco-motion
- On va autant parler
aux étuderererererererererereree
les intervenants psychosociaux,
mais aussi les enseignants.
Donc, comment mieux communiquer
d'une manière qui est pas
paralysante, qui va pas,
finalement... nuire
à l'action climatique.
mieux maîtriser la situationet r
son écoanxiété. Isabelle
qu'elle entend.
- Ça, c'est quelque chose
qu'on entend souvent :
me projeter dans le futur,
mes rêves, mes p
mon choix de carrière.
Je veux-tu avoir des enfants
questions assez existentielles.
- Ces senttttttt
exacerbés par l'impression que
les gouvernements n'en font pas
Pour Noémie Larouche, il est
impoieieieieieien accueillir
les émotions qui s'expriment.
- C'est de reconnaître
éprouve, de ce qu'elle éprouve.
rmrmrmrmrmrmal d'être en colère,
de vivre de l'anxiété...
de se sentir impuissant
de son environnement;eseseseses.
- Une étude publiée en 2021
menée auprès de 10 000 jeququque
60 % d'entdidididididisent
très inquiets, voireetetetetete,
par les s s s s s s climatiques.
Ici Élisa Serre